good morning Hank it's Monday so the
brilliant Michael Buckley has started
doing this advice show called dear buck
link in the doobly-doo and I have been
inspired by him to try to dispense some
of my own advice so I asked nerdfighters
on Twitter if they had any problems it
turns out that they do and I'm going to
do a advice today and then I'm also
gonna do advice on Friday um with the
caveat that my advice may suck I'm
scared to go to college so far away how
am I gonna deal with being lonely and
homesick I'll tell you how that
generally gets dealt with my college
freshman it generally gets dealt with by
binge drinking which you'll be surprised
to learn I don't recommend there's this
feeling on American college campuses
that the best way to achieve intimacy is
to get drunk with someone and throw up
on them maybe I'm just old fashioned but
it seems to me that throwing up on
another human being is not an act of
friendship it's kind of an act of yuck
the thing to remember about being a
college freshman is that everyone is in
the same boat you are
it's like alligators they're just as
afraid of you as you are of them I think
I need to cut out a subplot of my story
but it means rewriting the first half of
my novel what should I do
you should rewrite the first half of
your novel don't complain to me about
rewriting the first draft of this book
was like 62 thousand words long and I
ended up cutting 55 thousand of them
you're not gonna get any sympathy from
me on that front mister all writing is
rewriting this guy who maybe likes me
doesn't want our mutual friend and my
ex-boyfriend to find out what's up with
that this guy maybe likes you no I don't
like the cut of this guy's jib with his
maybe liking you if you're gonna be in a
romantic relationship with someone that
person shouldn't maybe like you the fact
that this boy is unwilling to taunt your
friend and ex-boyfriend with his
affection for you is another problem
entirely in fact I would argue it's
potentially not a problem at all but
don't bother with someone who maybe
likes you how can I get more nerdfighter
friends IRL
I'd recommend wearing your pizza shirt
everywhere you go until someone's like
oh I recognize that guy I got a job
interview today what can I do to stand
out I would personally recommend the
pizza suit but you should bear in mind
that I have never gotten a job as a
result of an interview my boyfriend says
I'm too smart for him but I really like
him should I start acting stupid
it's only a few things in this world
that turned me into a giant squid of
anger and one of them begins my
boyfriend thinks I'm too smart for him
I've said it before and I'll say it
again the Venn diagram of boys who don't
like smart girls and boys you don't want
a date is a circle mad at you boy who's
dating girl who follows me on Twitter
how do I get my best friend out of
denial about liking me I think we need
to consider the possibility that your
best friend is not in denial but instead
just doesn't like you which is okay
there are going to be in your life some
people who do not want to kiss you and
if you're not able to reconcile yourself
to that fact you're gonna have kind of a
weird miserable life of narcissism I
think you're the hiccups patience
grasshopper
patience when it comes to hiccups and
also when it comes to everything else
I'd like to remind myself that every
other time I thought something wasn't
going to end it ended I can't get Justin
Bieber songs out of my head help no I'm
not a physician I'm just a guy who's
wearing a cheap suit jacket no pants and
my own face on a shirt but when people
come to me suffering from Bieber fever I
always prescribe a heavy dose of the
mountain goats in fact there should be a
website called the mountain goats who
will cure your Bieber fever calm wait
that website exists
god I love the Internet Hank
nerdfighters please enjoy the mountain
goats will cure your beaver fever calm
there's a link in the doobly-doo I will
be dispensing more advice on Friday so
if you have problems leave them in the
comments Hank oh you had a great time at
Woodstock and I'll see you on Wednesday